you leave these doors tonight after
party with Jack then what where's that
relationship going and gonna wait and
see how it is where are we taking this
thing are we making the move to LA to be
with her oh man am i making the move to
LA I don't know do I have a job guys I
need help
you know sis and I have gotten to spend
some time together in jury house as well
outside of the cameras and everything
you haven't been with each other in kind
of a real-world situation so I don't
know what we're both gonna be like once
we get our phones back and we get other
people into our lives she's just a
beautiful spontaneous fun-loving person
and I really have enjoyed my time with
her I haven't been this happy in a
really long time and it's it's really
unique in my life to see that and I I
can't wait to meet her family and I
can't wait to see what real life is like
spending time with her outside of the
Big Brother it's kind of like a reverse
thing you live together and then you get
to know each other and it's paid off for
a lot of people there are a lot of show
manses it's still true but I'm so young
so I don't know I would love to
experience it with him but if not then
I'm would love having him just as a
friend
but you're gonna do whatever it takes to
make it work what's the plan
Wow I think we both have to see what our
lives look like right now on the other
side what you know a career is where a
career is headed for me where a career
is headed for her she just graduated
college and got out of a really long
relationship she's really looking to
live it up and I wouldn't mind hopping
along and joining her with it so we'll
definitely see I'm definitely in a part
of my life where I'm looking to do
spontaneous things and have fun and and
just be as present as possible but
definitely looking forward to you know
spreading is spreading as much care as I
possibly can moving forward see what
happens
go with the flow I'll let you guys know
time to act like a chicken and lay the
eggs can you ever look at a chicken the
same way again
no I will never be able to look at a
chicken the same I'm only known for
being a chicken but I don't really like
eggs that much anymore either and I
don't ever want to wear that [ __ ] in
costume ever again there were feathers
everywhere everywhere it's crazy
alright so sticking with big brother but
goodbye to the chicken costume it's
maybe on Jack enjoy the night welcome
back to the real world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]